Okay, time for a quiz. Okay, create template that
when provided with the variable n prints FizzBuzz up to
n. Now, what is FizzBuzz? FizzBuzz is, is a
little programming test that's easy, it's, it's a quick way
to see if somebody actually knows how to program
simple things or not. Basically when you do FizzBuzz, I
want you to follow this logic. If n is
divisible by 3, I want you to print Fizz. If
n is divisible by 5, I want you to print Buzz. And if n
is divisible by 3 and 5, I want you to
report FizzBuzz. And if it's not divisible by 3 or 5, just print
the number. Let me show you what this will
look like when it's working. Okay, so here is
a working FizzBuzz app. I'm just going to ask you
to paste in the template for a FizzBuzz, but here's,
here's what it looks like. So if we were
to say FizzBuzz of n equals 100. This is
what it would print, one, two, three is divisible
by three. So it would print fizz, five is
divisible by five, so print buzz. Four is neither.
Six is three so print fizz. Come down here
to 15 we print FizzBuzz. So as you see
anything divisible three or five prints fizz or Buzz,
both Fizz and Buzz. And if it's neither, it just
prints the number. And the source that we generated looks
like this. It's an ordered list and then I'm just
printing list elements for each value as we count up
to n is 100. As you can see n equals
100 down here. The handler that I'm using looks something
like this. I just added this to the end of
the file we've been working in. I made a new url
called FizzBuzz which uses FizzBuzzHandler. Which is defined
here, which inherits from Handler. And it gets
n from the request defaulting to zero, converts
it to an integer. n and int(n) is
the same as basically saying if n, n
equals int(n). And then we're rendering fizzbuzz.html passing
in n equals n. What I want you to do for this quiz is generate fizzbuzz.html.
And once you've got that working, I'd like
you to paste that right here. Okay, good luck.